madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
ministre mes chers collègues au fond la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
rayant d'un trait plume le travail du
Parlement sur la loi immigration et la
crise qu'exprime les agriculteurs nous
raconte la même histoire celle de ces
injonction que le peuple français ne
supporte plus de subir de la part tantôt
de juges supranationaux tantôt de juges
nationaux tantôt de technocrates
bruxellois ou parisiens mais ayant tous
tous en commun de ne jamais avoir de
compte à rendre au français si la
souveraineté nationale peut à ce point
être évitée contournée bafouée comment
s'étonner alors que la politique laisse
à penser aux yeux des Français qu'elle
est devenue une farce comment s'étonner
qu'ils en viennent à vouloir renverser
la
table dans ce monde dans ce moment
critique de notre histoire dans cette
démocratie en Chise qui est devenue la
France chacun d'entre nous se doit
d'agir avec plus de sens des
responsabilités que JAMA
sur l'immigration les Français exigent
un sursaut vous leur livrez un tour de
pass-p les Français en métropole ou en
outr n'en peuvent plus des discours
creux de vos catalogues La Redoute de
promesses jamais tenu vous osez nous
dire que depuis 2017 vous avez défendu
la souveraineté industrielle quelle
plaisanterie vous avez vendu Alstom
Alcatel Technip et vous laissz
démenteler aos comment vous croire vous
nous parlez d'alléger le fardeau des
normes pour les agriculteurs
mais il y a à peine plus d'un an au
salon de l'agriculture votre
prédécesseur avait déjà promis la fin de
la surtransposition des normes
environnemental et dans son univers
parallèle votre administration est en
train d'élaborer des cartes de
protection des tourbières qui vont
concerner 30 % de nos surfaces agricoles
voilà comment vous trompez les
cultivateurs et ce n'est pas en
supprimant Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au arrêtés préfectoraux que vous allez
changer quoi que ce soit vous nous aviez
promis des prix de rémunération avec
égalim et en ce moment même l'actalis
propose au producteurs de lait un prix
de 40 centimes quand leur coût de
revient est à 48 centimes voilà comment
vous Bernez les éleveurs il y a un an
nous avons voté à l'unanimité de cette
assemblée un calcul plus favorable pour
la retraite des agriculteurs depuis 1 an
vous faites tout pour que cette loi ne
soit pas appliqué il y a 8 mois nous
avons voté ici une résolution demandant
au gouvernement de s'opposé à la
ratification du Mercosur il aur a fallu
attendre hier pour que le Président de
la République Pride de panique dans un
Paris assiégé demande enfin à Madame V
derleiden d'arrêter les négociations
dans ce même réveil brutal on nous dit
que le président Macron serait désormais
prêt à partir en croisade contre les 4 %
de jaer de la PAC mais que ne l'a-t-il
fait plutôt la chaise vide du général de
Gaulle se faisait mieux entendre que la
chaise occupée du président Macron
la politique ce n'est pas que de la
communication un catalogue d'annonces
sans que ni tête ce n'est pas du théâtre
c'est la vie des Français c'est le sort
de notre
pays vous entendre dire qu'on a décidé
de mettre l'agriculture au-dessus de
tout fut un moment formidable j'ai
tellement eu envie d'y croire et puis je
me suis dit que cette phrase me
rappelait quelque chose et je me suis
souvenu que la semaine d'avant c'était
l'hôpital qui était la priorité absolue
et celle encore avant c'était l'école et
la semaine prochaine ce sera autre chose
peut-être l'écologie la culture et alors
tant pis pour l'agriculture sur la crise
agricole comme sur l'immigration les
Français ne se contenteront pas d'une
Story sur Instagram Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ou d'une vidéo TikTok autour
d'une botte de paille ils veulent des
résultats dans la vraie vie je vous le
dis très clairement Monsieur le Premier
Ministre tant que les réponses ne seront
pas là nous ne vous lâcherons pas la
terrible réalité c'est qu'après 7 ans
d'agit fiévreuse à coup d'annonce choc
de grands plans de grands débats
d'entretien de sanie il ne s'est rien
passé vous êtes passé sur les mauxs du
pays comme des courants d'air après 7
ans de pouvoir absolu à vous écouter
vous semblez seulement seulement
découvrir le pays mais les crises
sociales se succèdent le pays est
exangle fracturé révolté ces crises
comme cell des gilets jaunes ont toutes
en commun que vous ne les voyez jamais
venir parce que vous n'êtes pas dans la
vraie vie des Français
votre politique n'enthousiasme en
réalité que ceux qui n'attendent rien de
la politique c'est premiers de cordé
cher au président qui depuis longtemps
se sont émancipés et pensent ne plus
avoir grand-chose en commun avec le
reste du peuple français mais la France
qui a le plus besoin d'un pouvoir qui la
protège d'une concurrence déloyale
agriculteur ouvriers patron de petites
industries la France qui a le plus
besoin de servicees publics d'écoles
d'hôpitaux la France qui n'a plus de
médecins la France qui a besoin que l'on
remette de l'ordre qu'on enferme ces
dealers qui menacent ses enfants
celle-là vous ne la voyez pas vous ne
l'entendez pas et vous la laissez
s'enfoncer dans la colère comment s'en
étonner de la part d'un président pour
qui il y a deux catégories de français
ceux qui ont réussi et ceux qui ne sont
rien monsieur le monsieur le Premier
ministre derrière la communication la
réalité c'est l'échec de ce 7 années de
pouvoir du Président de la République
les résultats sont là monsieur le maire
depuis 7 ans en ramarqué de son
empreinte ou plutôt de ses empreuns son
passage au ministère des Finances
creusant avec une assid avec assiduité
une dette àissale de 3088 milliards
d'euros ce sont 900 milliards d'euros de
plus qu'à la fin du quinquena de
François Hollande en 2023 le déficit est
pire que prévu 173 milliards d'euros et
vous osez venir nous dire que vous
faites preuve d'une responsabilité
exemplaire en matière de finances
publiqu de qui vous moquez-vous et tout
ça pour quel résultat la croissance est
en berne 0,8 % en 2023 et pas mieux pour
2024 le pouvoir d'achat des Français est
encore peu plus encore un peu plus
attaqué par l'inflation et les années
que vous aurez perdu par vos Herms sur
le nucléaire à faire du suivisme
derrière les écologistes vous place
désormais dans une situation abérrante
où vous allez à la fois augmenter la
facture des ménages et faire perdre à
nos entreprises leur dernière avant
de
compétitivité au ministère de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin accueille
plus de 500000 étrangers par an c'est en
moyenne sous le SEPA Macron deux fois
plus que sous le quinquena de Nicolas
Sarkozi quant à l'insécurité nous en
sommes à 362000 coups et blessures en
2023 60 % de plus qu'en 2017 depuis 50
ans la France n'a jamais enregistré
autant d'omicide ou de tentativ
d'omicide magnifique record pour votre
gouvernement en matière d'éducation vous
savez la mer des batailles la France
s'effondre au classement PISA 10e dans
les années 2000 elle est aujourd'hui 23e
en sciences et en math 25e en lecture
vous êtes au pouvoir depuis 7 ans c'est
votre bilan vous avez également créé une
crise du logement sans précédent on ne
construit plus les Français ont de plus
en plus de difficultés à accéder à la
propriété votre système mapre renve
réussit exploit de rendre les travaux
d'isolation désormais inaccessibles à la
fois aux classes moyennees jugé trop
riches et aux foyers les plus modestes
incapable évidemment de financer des
rénovations globales cette crise est
telle qu'on voit désormais en France en
2024 des salariés dormir dans leur
voiture alors quand vous nous parlez de
choc d'offre de simplification des
normes d'accélération des procédures
permettez-nous de penser que c'est un
peu court enfin le bilan des ané Macron
c'est aussi un concernant
affaiblissement de la parole de la
France à l'internationale cette
singularité française que nous
chérissions tous ici a fait les frais
des attermoimments des paroles
maladroites ou des gestes déplacés des
coups de commes sans lendemain du
président de la République renvoyer sans
ménagement d'Afrique décrédibilisé au
Liban snobé au Maroc inaudible sur la
guerre en Ukraine hésitant sur Israël la
lucidité impose de reconnaître que
quelque chose s'est brisé de l'image de
notre pays aux yeux du monde Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous nous auriez
demandé notre confiance après ces 7
années de pouvoir nous n'aurions
évidemment pas pu vous la donner mais
nous ne vous empêcherons pas d'agir aije
besoin de rappeler que sans notre
soutien les rares réformes de
redressement de ce pays retraite chômage
RSA n'aurait pas vu le jour au contraire
au contraire nous vous pressons d'agir
sans délai pour les agriculteurs pour
reprendre le contrôle vraiment de notre
immigration pour faire vraiment respter
la loi de la République partout sur
notre territoire nous l'avons bien
compris ce remaniement ministériel vise
davantage à infléchir le cours des
sondages que de
l'histoire ce n'est pourtant pas la
communication qui fera la réussite de ce
gouvernement c'est sa capacité à écouter
et à respecter les Français leurs
attentes français que nous représentons
tous ici dans cette hémicycle dans
l'intérêt du pays Monsieur le Premier
Ministre tâchez de faire mieux que ce
qui vous a demandé par le président et
que la durée de vie de votre
gouvernement ne dépend pas que du
président de la République mais aussi de
cette Assemblée nationale où vous êtes
minoritaire et dont vous n'aurez pas la
confiance merci beaucoup monsieur le
président